well let's say hello to Judith holgar
and welcome her to the show hello Judith
hi Judith how are you good how are you
I'm fine thank you it's late in Budapest
that was where I was going to ask are
you a home after Norway
like you're in auto
well you're correct
I'm writing with you in the auto what's
uh what's going on
well we were changing some change of
times when I can show up on your show
and well I couldn't change my plans so
now I'm here in the car right well thank
you so much for making time to join us
have you been following the Karen's cup
well to tell you the truth only so very
few shots but not really right you just
done commentary duties yourself in
Norway stabbinger and that was a
fantastic tournament I mean wow uh great
great stuff Judith uh tell us a bit
about your experience in Norway
oh wow in Norway it was an amazing event
I must say it was uh quite incredible to
see the different generation of clash
and I think uh well I found it very
amazing to see them how to see the old
timers kind of Mama jarov and
and see Magnus he's uh he is also from
the oldies right
well I don't want to think of Magnus as
the oldies but go on
friends old man
how his his
seeing and following his Focus to follow
Carolina playing incredibly well the
tournament he was completely deserve to
be the winner I must say he made this
incredible game against firoza
sacrificing a rook but I have to admit
that Nakamura the number one streamer he
was the most amazing collecting the full
point in the last round versus Carolina
and won the tournament
and actually speaking of all this we
have a tournament winner already and it
was Anna zatonski who won the tournament
and she said in the interview that she
wanted to prove that age is just a
number would you agree with that
generally saying yes
but I think age is is not stopping you
perform very well because of your age
it's more of you can make a lot of
profit out of your experience at the
same time sometimes age makes it
difficult to not motivate yourself I
believe and look for new challenges we
are which you're very eager to
accomplish
interesting Judith I had a question that
I've been wanting to ask you for quite
some time when will a woman win the
World Chess Championship title overall
to tell you
either the most
[Music]
going to see more ladies in the top 10
or 20 in the world all right because the
football champion you have to be a very
special character whether you're a lady
man
because let's face it we didn't have so
many chess uh world champions uh in open
section either right you have to have
extremely
uh detailed worked out skills to be able
to become a world champion
like five women in the top 20 then see
one become world champion okay so when
are we gonna see five women in the top
20.
um I think it will be like 10 years
possibly
but there has to be some changes and I
think it goes back to
General the house Society is taking
girls when they want to play chess
how secure the environment is how much
the
parents are supportive on their success
how much a coach dealing with their
talents whether they are supporting and
encouraging them to become the best
chess players they can or they want to
challenge them and Inspire them only in
the women's section
fair fair enough uh before we let you go
one more question what's what are you up
to what's coming up next for you
well I have some big projects going on
I'm working on a book series for
children with based on my method and I'm
going to be traveling again in two weeks
in first half of July to Chile to make
some chess promotion tour Chile wow
wonderful well thank you thank you for
joining us in your car ride and giving
us vertigo and emotion sickness uh thank
you Judith thank you so much okay bye
bye bye as Judith Polgar going through
the streets of Budapest and who is she
well if you don't know Julie poger you
don't know chess right yes exactly she
became a Grandmaster at age 15. highest
rated female player of all time defeated
11 world champions including Gary
Kasparov and Magnus Carlson wow that
says a lot right there and in 2021 she
was inducted in the World Chess Hall of
Fame absolutely and for me